one of the core ideas of thomas
piketty's book is if the return on
capital is greater than the growth in
economy then that could drive inequality
that could drive
inequality
inequality and inequality is a natural
byproduct of a market capitalist economy
and
one could argue that hey look some
inequality is is going to happen as as
you grow your economy and you let people
be entrepreneurial and some people get
lucky some people less lucky some people
work harder some people work less hard
some people are able to allocate capital
well some people aren't so it all comes
into it but in extreme forms maybe this
is bad and in particular maybe this is
bad for democracy
so
bad for democracy right over here maybe
too much power starts to accrue in some
ways and maybe that and in the worst
case because that kind of starts to
drive it in on itself it actually might
even hurt economic growth if you don't
have enough consumers or or people with
enough purchasing power or discretionary
income or whatever else but what i
really want to focus on here
is not so much whether these causalities
are actually there or how much we should
worry about them once again my point
isn't to to give an opinion on whether i
agree or disagree with some or all of
the book it's really just give you a
framework because i think the book at
least raises an interesting conversation
and it gives us a lot of a lot of i
would say fodder for interesting
analysis and critical thinking and
that's really what i want you to walk
away with how do you think about these
things and you just need to make your
own judgment so what i want to do here
is at least show a circumstance that
this might be
returns on capital being greater than
economic growth can be a reasonable
proxy for rising inequality and of
course we you know this connection over
here is even kind of a harder thing to
necessarily draw the connection
but this even this one isn't always
going to be
isn't always going to be the case and to
think about that let's just imagine a an
economy where the whole economy just
produces
it just produces apples
so
let's say the whole economy right over
here
this is our whole our entire economy and
let me copy and paste it
so copy
and paste it i'm going to paste it to
show the growth in the economy so let's
say in year one
so this is year one right over here
year one it produced it produced one
thousand apples
one thousand
apples
and let's say in year two
year two
we have we have economic growth so let
me draw that so g
going from year one to year two let's
say that this is equal to two
percent so two percent of a thousand
would be twenty more apples so in year
two the economy produces a thousand
twenty
a thousand
twenty apples right over there
now let's say that in year one
in year one of the thousand apples that
were produced
let's say that
500 of them i'll just split in half
let's say 500 of them go to the owners
of capital
500 to
the owners
of capital now what's the owners of
capital what do they own and once again
it's a very simple economy that only has
one industry right over here but the
owners of capital are the people who
would own the orchard who own the trees
who own the machinery whatever they need
to pick the cat the the apples and let's
say that the other 500 goes to labor
to
500 to
labor
and let's say that the value of the
capital here
so the value
of
capital in apples we're just assuming
everything going on here is apples that
i guess to buy this apple orchard the
owner of it had to give let's say 4 000
apples
4 000
so given this what is the return on
capital in year one
well the return on capital i'll just
write return
on capital
capital in year one is going to be well
the return is 500 apples 500 apples
divided by the cost or i guess we say
the value of the capital
so divided by 4
000 apples so that's going to give us 5
5 divided by
that's the same thing as 5 divided by 40
which is 1 8 so that's going to be 12.5
percent
12.5 percent so return on capital at
least in year one is greater than is
well let's go to year two so we can look
at the return on capital in year two and
compare it and compare it to the growth
right over here and so let's just say
that the value that overheat the value
of the capital that all of it was
reinvested so now the value of the
capital
value
of capital
is now 4 000 plus 500 more apples so 45
4500 apples they reinvested in the
business and they didn't necessarily use
the apples as capital but they use those
extra 500 apples to go buy some more
machinery or buy some more land whatever
it might be
and let's say though that the laborer
had a little bit of leverage this year
so in this year because labor had
leverage only 500 still goes to the
owners of capital now this isn't
necessarily going to be the case if the
owners of the capital have leverage
maybe they could negotiate the other way
but let's say in this situation still
500 goes to
labor
500 goes sorry 500 goes to capital
capital
and here 520.
520 would go to labor
to
labor
so now what's the return on capital the
return on capital now is going to be
still 500 apples 500 apples
divided by
divided by 4 500
4500 apples
which is going to be this is now going
to be equal to
1 9 which is the same thing as what is
that 0.99 so let's see or actually
0.1111 let me just one divided by 9 you
have this 0.11111 so it's going to be
approximately 11 percent or let's say
11.1 percent approximately 11.1 percent
now the whole reason why i wanted to
show that why i did this diagram is this
is a situation where r is greater than g
our return on capital is 12.5 percent
going to 11.1 percent both of these
numbers are much larger than our growth
of the entire economy but even though
that's happening you actually don't have
rising inequality over here in this
situation of course i work the numbers
to make this happen i could have worked
them the other way but in this situation
it's not necessarily the case that r
being greater than g
led to more inequality now in future
videos i'll do some spreadsheets where
you see if r stays constant at a
constant value higher than g that will
lead to inequality but the whole reason
why i did this one is to show you that
just in a given period of time r being
greater than g doesn't necessarily mean
more inequality in this case
labor
labor got more of a fraction of the
total national income and once again the
connection between capital and labor and
and income inequality is that in general
in general the income that goes to labor
is more indicative of the income that
might go to the lower quartiles of a
population and the income that goes to
capital is more indicative of of the
income that might go to the top
percentile or decile because capital
tends to be concentrated in the top few
sections